benvenuti a nuovi episodi di esperimenti
incredibile con totò con e risparmio
kratom oggi qui perché noi fare
l'esperimento per invalidare la fisica
come terra mare contro le leggi della
andare contro le leggi della fisica
acqua inservienti c'è qualcosa che non
va c'è qualcosa che non va o cinta toria
che non capisco ma chi è che organizzata
questi video di
[Musica]
buon john studenti com benvenuti questo
episodio di esperimento incredibile va a
mettere il meeting le fette di stati
mente fatto l'esperimento di oggi è
riempire un bicchiere al contrario a
cicli gatto è pronto per fare nuovo
esperimento per voi da questo
esperimento tutorial cose semplicissime
utilizzare con sanzioni fi che in
italiano significa utilizzare anche una
[Musica]
totali non potervi dire questa parola
perché non essere family friendly in
italiano significa quindi dottore
utilizzare fa un cazzo
per fare esperimenti nell'esperimento
del esperimento molto facile sperimento
può fare anche bambino
in un bambino non fa che star in tutto
va bene prendere candela
però prima servire acqua dove assaggiare
aqua blue e pd buffo fare un po di
tentativi oggi esperimento molto
semplice rispetto al solito però tutto è
non ricordare quindi difficoltà
aumentata dottore fare dei test
accendere una volta c'era sarah
bicchiere
torre non aveva bisogno di effetti
esterni che dovevo uscire anche senza
avere bisogno di battisti
[Musica]
suono cristallino che aveva funzionato
fare esperimento con come avete visto
prima ma acqua adesso andrà ri di sopra
a quando funzionato e tantissimo a
raccomandare di sotto quindi seriamente
un po strano per riuscire a non dare
acqua ma antica riempire tutto i
bicchieri di acqua di totò inserire il
bicchiere per coprire candela in teoria
candela dovrebbe spegnersi ma se
l'esperimento riesce candela funziona se
bicchiere scoppia un dottore potrebbe
momento
candela fatta scoprire come si dice
scopi ai centesi altrimenti non poteva
essere ma acqua non salita in superficie
e servi esperimento pato non funzionare
molto bene
sperimento torre anche un po cantato
sotto per troppa di colpa chi non è che
ferimento funzionante totò è fortissimo
esperimento riuscito perché il dottore
studiato da dover saper riconoscere
successi e fallimenti fallimenti non
esserci in totò torre sempre successo
greenwood giove per concludere
esperimento riuscito a scendere la e
sirigu vuol dire queste pro quindi se
google censura video google cin suo
grazie stesso sa accendere dottore
bruciato perché dottore non fumo dovendo
un mito torres perché esperimento vi sia
piaciuto
ricordate se non avete di meglio da fare
seguite dottore che insegna sempre cose
nuove cose belle cose carine che le
candele primo siano un sacco quando fate
più anniversario
la fidanzata aver bella davvero questo a
bere un bicchiere
mettete l'acqua sul tavo fatto il
cassino ma ragazza poi in moto una cosa
di poco a salire e spera in netto finito
esperimento riuscito se il video mi è
piaciuto e lasciate un bel mi piace e
come sia pratici archivia l'anno
prossimo
[Musica]